five mixing up his wake-up options
and that's the thing that showed that he
didn't know that
he could not really just employ his
throw pressure like that the threat up
oh
no way the comeback
oh the wall was in there right
oh he broke
and we saved those four into the
uppercut launch that was crazy
wow the wall pressure here
oh this could come with a low period
here to take the pressure off he's going
to get some damage oh
spit on oh he spit the gas that's going
to hurt right back it's going to hurt
not dead not dead but very close
oh was fishing for a counter hit
oh he had it right the mid pressure
doesn't matter three
like that double willing to just take
his touch get the health lead
cat stance he just dips on out that time
tries to press the issue pina we're
ready with the answer
while standing one let's go baby
up kids get towards the wall
the season three walking version oh
claps him up
oh man don't don't be a victim to the
rage not like this oh my goodness
two
the follow up here nice launch he's
gonna also push towards the other side
of the stage gets the second wall
wall
finds his low finds his mid
yo he's running out of there oh one more
he could do it
gets the phone to what
into what he's going to make this
comeback is it enough drop oh it's
enough from the top rope one
man double is playing out of his mind
with law
yo this is one step he goes for maximum
damage into the upper cause the wall
messed them up this is bad both players
enraged
how are you going to deal with it the
duck he didn't get anything afterwards
he's just a hair just look up it's so oh
my goodness
he's dead
why would you of all situations you're
gonna go for the manual parry
[Music]
[Music]
you